je porte le poids et la souffrance que
l'être à bail malik et du coup j'ai du
mal à entendre la même chose en large et
j'ai plongé là où la pression prend la
place de la fonction j'ai plongé là où
la raison c'est déjà fait de ballades
des principes visant pour le coop
rattache été lacérée parce qu'ils ont
refusé les offres que le vi a fait fi
des principes sont si pauvres aveugle et
dépareillée pendant que le vivre ou
longo va avec le siège a fait 7 juin des
seules à résister le vice prime des
m'agripper à moi tout seul chez une
équipe car je suis seul mais a dit moi
j'aimais running des monsif mon
endurance et aller s'il faut respirer
l'air du couvre alors je fais de la
peine même si je puis on a des poissons
à la dérive dans le bocal devils à
grandir il décore le destin dessine en
apnée nage à contre courant en courant
de mon estime pour te coller faut que
j'aille nager à la piscine en apnée
perds mon innocence dans les profondeurs
éloquente la surface est trop lente seul
le groove mauriange en apnée d'un succès
avant de savoir rap et augmente ne songe
que le chemin à l'envers fais gaffe on
va se croiser et pourtant ma voix parce
que ma foi ça fait parti d'un vrai état
d'esprit tellement froid que kris lim a
mis un j'aime les m6 plein de l'état
dans la gloire ils sont un vrai espoir
corps parce qu'ils aboient sans espoir
font les chiens
tu veux être polémique t'es juste
bruyante et pas puissante a juste qu'on
s'équipe t'es pas méchant juste
colérique la rue c'est cops et santé
c'est dur de coexister que des robots
qui décide et des poteaux qui décède
alors seul le coeur et les rivières ma
carrière j'ai laissé l'oseille et la
stricte à l'arrière ça vaut pas un
salaire
ym aiguiser le succès machette pas
perdre mais qu'ils aient caché sous le
palais site showbiz411 sentimentale tant
que rappeur hardcore matinale comme
l'aurore mental de fer spip à l'aéroport
taboye porte des rimes l'entente la
tienne porte défaut je présenterai
l'excellence avec qui je danse des cils
embauché une entité même si je prend de
l'altitude géré par oubli plus d'un an
mais c'est pas beau sale tronche
respirer votre oxygène aseptisé mes
rêves avec vos torchons trop d'hygiène
où aller gros dilemme accouchement fonds
sous votre système en appelait dans la
crasse l'écrit et lectrices quotidienne
en apnée clan des fausse politesse des
fautes carrés séparés par la richesse le
bis le crise la thèse je quitte les
bassins comme la peste dans des
histoires romanesques la street
credibility vous à l'aise je vous la
laisse j'ai ma n en ai passé ma peine à
réparer le futur a préparé le soleil 100
hectares et en rêvant devrait pas les
les gens crèvent sur le pavé les vrais
savent mais les vrais se taisent dans la
flemme d'aller parler en apnée pente à
la surface pour décrire tellement rien à
dire là haut toujours le même
rien raté mais le pire commenté le
décrire que les m6 appel punchline ce
que j'appellerais on s'est menti que
même si je prend de l'altitude qui n'est
pas remplie plus d'un empire et la
cystine entité même si je prend de
l'altitude qui a tiré par amplitude un
empire a dit apprenez à les amener en
apnée merci